now I'm thinking Stephen A that because
we've we're into the we're into the
season a little bit here some rosters
have been established this probably
going to be a piece of cake for
you it ain't I've been I've been
footballed I've been listen got it
rarely does Chuck get rarely does Chuck
get two he gets one or none most of the
time ACC all right are we ready to play
who he play for We
Ready $20 bet I got I got Ste all right
let's do it for how many hey how many
going to get out of out of five Sten
going to get Stephen A going to get
three press on here it is here it is
player number one ish Smith D okay
Stephen A Smith where he was last who he
know he was last who he play for what
the hell is he Detroit now uh let's
see I Wasing a
wiz for one for one like Shaq at the
free throw line I'm I'm getting them I'm
getting them wrong I'm getting wrong
this is not good for me number
two come on y'all giving them tougher
ones than
I I think about no damn Dam these AR
tougher than Chuck they are Chuck help
me Chu oh don't you're asking for the
wrong guy no this is tougher Charlotte
Hornets we just had a I was
say it begins with a c I have a feeling
he's going to get this one just have a
feeling he's going to get strike three
and I'm out number three is Dante yeah
you got that you get that Dante hell no
he just talked about today he actually
he actually started for his team last
night come on man I give me no damn
answers all right I'm going to give you
a hint he started for his team he's in
Texas oh come on there's three teams in
Texas man give me one give me
one he said Houston but it's the Dallas
M hey Mike Mike 0 for three like sh at
the free throw line now oh my Lord how
about a Toronto was that Toronto yes he
is a Toronto
Raptor listen when I about I always
follow a
por when he standing when he standing a
wi forget that this guy is a whoy play
for Hall of f temp got to be
12 let me this to ch
the New Jersey Net oh you you missed it
on opening night and you missed it
tonight
too now why would I watch the Toronto
rapt because Toronto is your favorite
city it's my favorite city that I'm
never going to get to see again there
you go shout out
out I knew he was in Toronto that was
two out five I know he was in Toronto
yeah but that don't help my money sit
say that I was did you say Garrett
Temple was in Toronto yes okay two for
five two
for
but hey Stephen A Smith Michael wil love
you guys thank you bless
day